the aftermath of hurricane ida there's
still an urgent need for relief in
louisiana 11 more deaths have been
reported since yesterday now the
statewide total is now 26. more deaths
are blamed on heat and other causes in
louisiana than the hurricane itself but
around 250 000 people are still without
power
and it has been hot down there our lead
national correspondent david begno is in
a community which is still partly
underwater good morning dave
good morning underwater and cut off
listen we are 40 minutes outside the
city of new orleans but it might as well
be a world of way this area of jean
lafitte and baritaria is surrounded by
wetlands and marsh it's beautiful on a
good day on a bad day after a hurricane
it's miserable the main bridge was
basically cut off right it collapsed so
the national guard has set up a
temporary one and we crossed it two days
ago and spent the last 48 hours working
to tell this story
you can practically walk on water where
bayou baritaria separates jean lafitte
from barataria louisiana that grass is
marsh
thrust in by hurricane itis storm surge
which pushed a barge into the only
bridge connecting these two communities
that knocked out the bridge sunk the
barge and cut off the 1200 residents in
barateria when i get up to we went to
meet one of them nice to meet you sir
i'd like to talk to somebody it's nice
to talk to somebody my dog won't speak
to me
[Laughter]
robert gonzalo's home has been
surrounded by flood water for the last
10 days he's lived here for 42 years and
hurricane katrina was the only one he
evacuated for
i was expecting water but i wasn't
expecting this kind of water why didn't
you leave for this one uh
good question why didn't i
i don't know i just we just me and my
son decided to stay
you know just hang around his home is
eight feet off the ground and the water
came within a foot of flooding it that's
how high the water got up right here he
wrote out the hurricane at his
mother-in-law's house right next door it
used to be here but in the aftermath of
the storm flood water lifted it off of
its foundation and moved it nearly 10
yards you know
there's nothing that hurt me more
you see my mother's butterlog's house
float away
it's pretty rough
just down the street from here about a
mile
is where we met 77 year old earl trish
holding this
holding that
for more than three
hours keeping the wind
and rain down somewhat
the wind would blow so hard it would
blow me back
his home is high and dry
his wife evacuated but he refused to he
had a heart attack five months ago and
when we met him he had just run out of
his heart medication so his neighbor
lisa went and got it for him
that's the main thing i'm after when we
drove through barritaria we saw so many
people who had their personal belongings
at the road soaked this man wanted us to
see his horse that had run away during
the hurricane and was now a mile down
the road standing at someone's front
door
because it was dry there
around here pets are treated as well as
people
which brings us back to robert gonzalo
and thor
he says thor is the only reason he's
still here his wife and son already left
as for whether he's going to stick
around for another storm the size of ida
it won't ever happen again
never again
11 storm related deaths here in the
state of louisiana nine of them
have been heat related no power means no
air conditioning and the good folks here
in barateria have been told it'll
probably be the end of the month before
they get their power back
tony
david begno with the story of neighbors
helping neighbors and the continued
cleanup there from hurricane ida thor
looks like a very good boy david thank
you very much